for moms and dads listening it is fraud
if you open up credit cards and the
names of your children like and say that
it's you that's fraud and not only that
like you have the ability to really Jack
their credit I know people personally
who this has been done to them and then
they hit 18 and they get into the world
and they're 21 and 23 and they're like
why do like why is my credit already bad
like what's happened to me and they find
out it's cuz their parents have opened
up cards in their mess with your kids
Financial life and the other Trend I'm
seeing Jade and I'm seeing the all these
videos on Instagram and Tik Tok there's
all this advice saying hey add your kid
as an authorized user on your card even
if they're 3 years old when they're 18
they're going to have amazing credit and
they're going to be so grateful and
here's what happens the parents blow up
their kids credit Yeah by accident yes
and then screw up their kids Financial
life before they're even an adult